[Music]
the second battle for the philippines in
world war
ii was going to be fought under entirely
different circumstances than the first
time
again america and japan had blocked
horns over the strategic islands but
this time
the united states and its huge armada
would be the aggressor
it is considered a turning point in
world war ii
the battle of leyte gulf over four days
in october of 1944
allowed the allies to retake control of
the philippines from japan
more than 200 thousand naval personnel
took part in the battle
historians believe it to be the largest
naval confrontation
in world history the u.s navy lost seven
ships including the uss
johnston which had been unseen by
human eyes for nearly 80 years until
this week
david martin has the story at 20
thousand feet
visibility is very limited even with a
spotlight
but that whole number leaves no doubt
this is the wreck of the destroyer uss
johnston 75 years after it went down in
the last great naval battle
of world war ii johnston is one of the
most famous wrecks in all of naval
history
operating a submersible with an
unlimited diving depth
victor vescovo found the johnston four
miles beneath the philippine sea
the deepest wreck ever discovered much
deeper than the titanic
we kept going deeper and deeper and
deeper into the black then out of the
murk we could just slowly see the bow
what was that moment like
oh my goodness the guns of the ship were
still
pointed in the proper direction of where
they were firing when they went
down the ship still looked like it was
fighting like it just still
hadn't given up the entire crew either
went down with a ship or scrambled off
just before it sank 186 sailors
died all of those in the battle that
were lost the remains were never located
warren sterling's uncle elton was the
johnston's executive officer
have you ever found out exactly how he
perished
they were in the water for 52 hours
before being picked up
seems like he swam off and either he
drowned or a shark got him
the wreckage will remain untouched but
its discovery has brought to the surface
the astonishing story
of the uss johnston it's one of the most
valiant
actions in the entire history of the
united states navy
retired admiral samuel cox director of
the naval history command
has known the story of the johnston
since he was a little boy
i was into naval history before i could
read looking at pictures in my dad's
books
so i knew the story of ernest evans the
commander of the johnston
he was a childhood hero of mine
everybody should know the story of
commander ernest evans
and his actions at the battle of leyte
golf evans was the first native american
to be awarded
a medal of honor in the united states
navy
general douglas macarthur had just
waited ashore in the philippines
as the u.s closed in on japan and the
johnston was part of a naval force
protecting macarthur's supply ships on
the morning of the 25
october 1944 that force was surprised by
a vastly superior japanese force that
was able to
get through a straight undetected during
the night
and show up unexpected
this is an artist's depiction of the
johnston as commander evans led the
charge against the japanese armada
it was four battleships eight cruisers
and 11 destroyers
and without waiting for orders he turned
and took his ship and charged
that entire japanese force and was able
to put a torpedo in the lead japanese
cruiser
that sounds like a suicide chart if he
didn't do
something the japanese were going to
overrun and sink the entire force
then they're into general macarthur's
supply ships and troop transports
so what's at stake here is macarthur's
return to the philippines
essentially yes sir for a few desperate
hours off the philippine island of samar
evans and his ship were in the japanese
bullseye the first hits
basically killed multiple people on the
bridge
so he's trying to fight this battle
while standing in
dead bodies and body parts he's had two
of his fingers torn off
and yet he still has to maintain the
presence of mind to continue to
to fight that ship but the japanese guns
were too big
and too many johnston is dead in the
water and crippled
and these japanese destroyers are just
firing round after round after round
into the ship and finally johnston sinks
and one of the japanese commanding
officers was observed to actually
salute the u.s ship as it went down what
happened to evans
evans was last seen going into the water
as the ship sank
and then never seen again so how does
the battle end
the japanese commander turns away he's
on a do or die mission
yet he turned back it was one of the
most brave
last stands of a naval vessel in history
of true david and goliath battle
in the largest naval battle ever fought
on this planet the johnston is a burial
ground as sacred as arlington national
cemetery
before victor vescovo left he paid final
tribute to commander ernest
evans and the men who followed him into
battle to the johnson
for cbs this morning saturday david
martin
the pentagon story we were all saying
i didn't know yeah and at 21 000 feet 4
miles down that's almost twice as deep
as the titanic
yeah it sounds like a battle that truly
changed
the war worth remembering oh